près de 90 000 électeurs sont attendus
aux ions de dimanche 9 octobre dans la
deuxième circonscription composé des
communes des cantons de Vélizy
Versailles Sud Viroflay Chevreuse
Jean-Noël Barrault est arrivé en large
tête au premier tour député depuis 2017
jusqu'à sa nomination au gouvernement il
a recueilli
42,29% des voix Maïté qui arrive
bedouani s'est classé deuxième avec un
score de 18,6 % à quelques jours d'un
nouveau vote les deux candidats déjà
opposés en juin dernier jettent leur
dernière force dans la campagne présente
aux abords de la gare de Versailles
chantier mercredi soir pour Jean-Noël
Barrault le ministre délégué au
numérique enregistre pour ce second tour
les soutiens notamment du président du
Département et de l'UDI il souhaite
apporter davantage de poids à une
majorité seulement relative à
l'Assemblée la majorité est plus étroite
qu'auparavant que certaines des grandes
réformes que nous voulons mener
notamment pour la formation pour le
service public de l'emploi pour les
lycées professionnels ces grandes
réformes elles se joueront à une ou à
deux voies près ce sera peut-être la
mienne ou celle d'Anne bergante qui fera
la différence et donc je crois que
dimanche il faut le se mobiliser pour
par des propositions qui sont cohérentes
bédouani comptait dimanche dernier 24
points de retard sur son adversaire mais
en vue du second tour elle ne savoure
pas vaincu nous avons une très forte
abstention à ce premier tour
donc chaque voix compte
donc on ne peut rien présager mais tout
est possible reste à savoir
effectivement si les électeurs se
mobiliseront dimanche au premier tour
l'abstention a atteint 73,33% pour ce
scrutin partiel dans la deuxième
circonscription